extracurricular activities are what make
us up as human beings and they're really
important in terms our everyday life
however when it comes supplied to Oxford
they're not quite as important as you
might think when you can you see go on
college websites you might see there's a
range of activities going on and one of
our biggest selling points when we're
talking to students is about the range
of activities you can do alongside your
degree however at the point of
application you've got very few words to
actually sell yourself as a student
we're making academic decisions who are
actually making them based on how well
you can perform the potential that you
have to become and a better learner for
want of a better word if you think
remember I think is that extra flap chip
is a something that we do care about in
our students but when you're making it
an application to Oxford you need to
make it as relevant to the course that
are applying to as possible so for
instance if you apply for something like
music do mention your activities because
it demonstrates the passion everyone
talks about when right in person
statements however if you're going to be
writing a personal statement for another
subject and but you're very accomplished
in music perhaps it's better that you
use the yuccas form in a more creative
way by moving all those qualifications
over in the area called and designated
for additional qualifications and
concentrate instead on the academic
aspects of your profile that will really
bring your application to shine out
slightly more by looking less at your
actual activities at the point of
application and more on your academic
credentials at that point thank you so
much to Dan for agreeing to be
interviewed if you'd like to check out
more videos about Oxford and Cambridge
admissions then check out the playlist
that's on the screen now and linked in
the description below also take a look
at the social media links in the
description forcement Peter's College
which is my old college there are links
to Facebook Twitter snapchat and
Instagram where you can see a snapshot
of student life at an Oxford College